the monster verse is a mysterious and
scary world to be in
we have the biggest monsters that have
ever been created for the big screen
in the video we will showcase to you
more of what is behind the scenes
of the strange fantastical world if you
have watched king of the monsters till
the end then you might have seen the
writings
with credits that are blotted out just
later on to show the name of the
producer
or the screenwriter these blotted lines
have valuable information as to what
monarch has learned
about the titans and the prehistoric
human civilizations
and so we have worked hard to get all of
that info and we
have now stitched together the storyline
to go as follows
of course we have paraphrased a little
bit let's say 4
to 5 but the rest is taken from what is
given to us
we will also showcase the recent events
and dealings of monarch that might lead
up to the final movie
so we start with footage from the uss
scorpion submarine
which revealed many things which include
evidences that hollow earth ruins
predate all known human civilizations
and monarch then releases studies about
titans to the public
it showed that ancient humanity revered
and worshipped these titans and even
form
symbiotic relationships with some titans
other humans
scavenge fallen titans for food building
structures from bones and heights of
these titans
and with these massive horns were
created by ancient humanity to replicate
the call of the titans
each one of these ancient cultures
worship their own titan and some are
called as gods
the old ones and even dragons
these tribes of humans built their homes
near benevolent titans to protect
themselves from other hostile creatures
there are also evidences that humans may
have even developed telephonic
communication with the creatures and
even attempted to control them
to use them for warfare and even
succeeded as some titans rebelled
against their human masters
that a massive cataclysm destroyed this
ancient human civilization and triggered
a war
between man and monsters and after the
war
survivors scattered across the globe
forming colonies
and as time passed even oral tradition
were unable to preserve much knowledge
about these ancient cultures
evidence was found of these ancient
human colonies in egypt
north america europe asia and south
america
titans too were not invulnerable to the
geological catastrophes of ancient times
as
the cataclysm triggered the ice age
sending
the titans into hibernation and the
surviving members of humanity soon
forgot their connection to the creatures
they became legend and stories were
passed down orally and their history
becoming a blur of gods and monsters
of myths and legends fictionalized by
time
monarchs then went on to excavate the
ruins of these civilizations and extract
truths from their stories their
mythology became an intertwine a
centuries-old tapestry that needs to be
unraveled and learned
some believe that the titans are
essential to humanity's survival
and that the creatures were vital to the
planet's ecosystem
so if ancient humans lived in balance
with the creatures then so can modern
humanity
therefore monarch scientists then
embarked on missions to find dormant
titans all around the world
and mona found sleeping bees near many
major cities
monarch then explored the ruins in peru
vietnam
and easter island and seem to have
discovered a lot including an egg of
mothra
some are alarmed by their presence but
others believe that many titans are
intelligent and even sentient
some consider some of these styles to be
mystical deities
and so monarch operatives captured
several new specimens of titans
so these studies unearthed certain
evidence that only a god
or a very powerful thailand can bestow
the natural order
and not even other titans in association
with humans could bring balance to the
world
so what is a king to a god they
discovered cave paintings of common
godzilla which showed that there
are ancient rivalries lurking with
evidences of these
found in location 37.218705 north
38.855563 east which is
the southern eastern part of the country
of turkey
this brings the question that how long
will it take for the fires to awaken
and send our own civilization into
collapse then there is an image of
monarch with a snake titan
is this the final boss or the greatest
threat for both titan and humankind
and the last image of a cave painting
shifts to common godzilla in a battle
will these two titans kill themselves or
team up against another more deadly
and world-changing titan did this battle
really occur in the past or is it
that ancient humanity developed
telepathic links and even visions of
future events
is it a prophecy or was it another
battle between these two alpha super
species
so returning to the modern time we see
clippings of titans returning to their
natural environments
while rhodan is now nesting in a volcano
near fiji
a mysterious rainforest blooms in the
sahara desert
at the same time monarch reveals decades
of secrecy and now operates with full
transparency and there was a clipping of
godzilla bringing
wreaths back to life and population of
fishes increasing
due to his presence in the files monarch
confirms an ancient greek origin of
squid-like titan called cilla
which was the same one that emerged in
the united states and was seen
bowing down before the king of the
monsters in the end of godzilla kotm
we find out that godzilla keeps titans
in check defense cities from attacks and
keeps the natural order
so the question arises if godzilla has
an affinity
or was one of the titans worship and
maintain his soft spot for humanity
then we see that the behemoth titan
restores the forced regions
of the amazon from his after-effect
radiation
and the same goes with cilla which slows
down the ice melting in antarctica
stabilizing the sea levels there were
also unexpected results as
ecosystems heal and 14 animals are taken
off the endangered list
we also find out that titan waste could
be a viable energy source
and that massive ancient plants and
fruits resurfaced with tyrants which
could solve world hunger crisis
then there were seismic disturbances
reported in skull island and that the
new titans are mysteriously
drawn to the area so monarch boosted
their forces around skull island and we
can see that in fine print that
monarch was even creating a mechanized
titan in skull island
and also tried to create organic titans
as well but to no avail
at the same time monarch finds a massive
act deep within
mothra's territory in southern china
which could only mean the resurrection
of mothra
then there were a report of ancient
hollow earth humans that coexisted with
titans
so this led a monarch to set out and
explore the hollow
earth for the origins of these titans
and maybe how to live in harmony with
them
and this could only be done going
beneath skull island
so predictions for the events of the
next movie will be more likely true or
near true
if we take all this information into
account
given the fact that we know godzilla and
kong are going to fight the reason
behind it
is still a big question mark since the
monster verse must make a big bang with
the next flick
they could only put it off with another
world changing or doomsday event
and with the inclusion of a bigger
monster with many more titans battling
out
and even dying just to make things more
tragic one thing that everybody seems to
forget is that
in the post-credits scenes of king of
the monsters we have
one of ghidorah's heads acquired by alan
jonah
so there might be a probability of
resurrection of ghidorah
in either a mechanical form or
integrated in another mechanized titan
there is also a call from the fans to
bring in destoroyah and mecca godzilla
into the fray
and if that happens then this will be in
the same prestige as the 1969
all monsters attack or the 2004 godzilla
final walls
just to give a befitting end to the most
of her storyline anyway let's hope for
the best and prepare for the worst
so thanks for watching and do not forget
to hit that subscribe button for more
monsters
and godzilla videos in the future take
care my cues stay home and stay safe
[Music]